why don't we transition into the 15
minimum wage and what happened with that
okay 15
minimum wage what page are we there we
go so 15 dollar minimum wage
would cut employment uh uh
reduce poverty cbo study fines so so
it's both ways
so one it would cut unemployment it
would cut
employment but it would reduce poverty
so let's take a look at what happened
with the report that came back
increasing the federal minimum wage to
15 an hour by 2025 from the current rate
of 725
as president bibin has biden has called
for would cut
employment not unemployment employment
by 1.4 million jobs meaning 1.4 million
americans would lose their job
and reduce the number of americans below
poverty line by 900 000 according to a
study released by
nonpartisan congressional budget office
on monday
while more than 1 million would lose
their jobs that's 1.4 million
the report said that 17 million u.s
workers or about 10 percent of the labor
force
would have pay increases another 10
million workers who earn slightly more
than 15
an hour could also potentially see pay
raises because
if you're making 15 right now the other
guy's making 725 then the 725 becomes 15
the 15 is going to be like why am i
getting paid the same as a 725 guy
the 15 is going to go to 20 just because
the 725 now caught up
the study assumes as a june 1st
effective date for the bill raising the
federal minimum wage to 950 an hour
under the plan the wage would be
increased annually until it reaches 15
by 2025
from 2021 to 2023
the plan would increase payments to
workers by net 333 billion dollars after
accounting for wage increases and job
losses the study found
that would allow low income workers to
spend more but would increase
labor costs for businesses and raise
prices especially at restaurants the
loss of jobs would cause a modest
negative overall
impact on economic growth so the loss of
jobs would cause a
modest negative impact modest is the
word
use impact the accumulated federal
budget deficit from 2021 to 2031 would
increase by 54 billion
if a 15 minimum wage was enacted largely
because higher price of goods
and services would contribute to an
increase in federal spending the report
found thoughts so the
initial what comes to mind is
i'm going to go somewhere different with
this and i'll circle back is the power
of reason
and not just blindly following your
party all right so personal example i
remember a few years ago
i went and i interviewed a bunch of
people who were in the in florida
they were it's called the fight for 15
campaign
and they they're a lot of these people
work for big companies the airlines the
big box retailers they're not working
for little mom-and-pop shops
they're working for the amazons of the
world or the american airlines of the
world and they're fighting
protesting for 15 minimum wage so
instinctually i'm thinking yeah i'm on
the side of these people like they're
they're telling me they got to get two
jobs to fight for the you know to
to um to just sustain life um so
initially i'm thinking this is
ridiculous you gotta you know
and then i started researching this a
little bit more and then i started you
know i even
you did an episode about this about not
having minimum wage having
um a living wage right
and essentially what i've realized
is that these minimum wage increases
they sound
good a lot like socialism you know on
the surface they sound good
but when you actually run the numbers
and when you see that well
over a million people are going to lose
their jobs and there's actually going to
be some
adverse effects to this and it's not all
pretty and on the surface yeah of course
uh raising the minimum wage sounds good
but what are the ramifications of that
and you can kind of get into the numbers
here it's the numbers behind the story
tell a different
story basically so um
i'm in favor of certain big cities new
york city
you know san francisco you know states
having you know
15 federal minimum of a state minimum
wage
but tuscaloosa alabama if you have a
small little pizza shop and you have
three employees there and you're paying
them all
eight bucks an hour and now you're
paying them 15. they're going to go out
of business or at least
two of the people are going to get
increases you're going to fire the pizza
delivery guy whatever so
people are going to lose jobs like it
says here and some you know the poor
will get a little bit
uh what do you got so first thought
which was i added this
this chart is essentially i was looking
at the prices over time how much has it
jumped
how quick how quickly and where has it
been at since 1961
it's 60 years it's jumped from one
dollar
to seven 725 so six bucks
now in five years they want to jump that
again twice as much
which so it's jumped from a dollar
minimum wage in 1961
to essentially 15 15 times
they want to increase it from 1960 by
2031. is that the number by 2031
yeah that's not 20 25. 20 25 15 bucks so
it's 65 years
64 years they want to raise minimum wage
15 times
yeah and well for me it's also if you
look at uh so what are the previous
hikes been right yeah so we look in 61
it was a dollar and
78 it was 265. in 81 it's 331. in 1797
you got 5 15.
2007 it's 5.85
2009 it's 7.25 2025. now
15. what about a 10
or a 9
or something like that i think 15 is a
lot first of all because like adam
mentioned there's
um you see you have glo uh nationally
you don't have the same uh demand for
for
the workforce in smaller counties and
stuff like that so i'm more
a proponent of increasing a state uh
minimum leave it to federal leave it to
the state to decide what they're going
to be exactly
right or county even yeah because
you you can't do it and if you look at
it minimum wage jobs
are mostly entry-level jobs and they're
usually called like stepping stone jobs
you start here and then you kind of
build up some experience and then you
move on
or you move up uh who or what are the
jobs mostly it's kind of service
industry
and stuff like that where you can also
move up as you
grow an experience and you can get a
better job um
another thing you look at with with
increasing minimum wage you'll have an
increase of robots i mean if you go to
mcdonald's you can order now without
even talking to someone
soon enough there'll be a robot in the
kitchen as well
so at that point you're just speeding up
well if you the interest
of a business because if i'm if i'm
going to pay so what's going to have to
pay
go a little deeper there what else are
you speeding up if you raise minimum
wage and everybody's going to robots
you're speeding up unemployment no no
but what else are you speeding up
you're speeding up whose argument in the
last campaign
blew up on the liberal side who's our no
no one guy that came out of nowhere
entrepreneurs
which was what ubi ubi right if you
raise minimum wage
companies go to robots automation then
you're
speeding up the process of needing ubi
so the raising of minimum wage
forces us in the next 10 years to accept
a permanent
ubi or you're also and and before that i
think also
it's acceleration it's not it's not a
matter of it's not going to happen it's
going to happen eventually but you're
accelerating that process yeah and i
also think it's
did i make sense absolutely absolutely
and i think a big part of it
before ubi because again that's down the
road i see a quicker solution
is them uh scaling down obviously on
how many people you need and then also
you have an
increase in sending jobs out where it's
there's a cheaper labor force just just
to
lay this up for you give us the pros and
cons of where you're at with the minimum
wage thing because i know this is
something that you've been
you know uh pretty vocal about on
valuetainment but where are you at with
them that's great
the math doesn't make sense okay because
look you know
how many pennies in a dollar a hundred
you can't do anything about that that's
math
there's nothing you can do to say can we
have 200 pennies in a dollar no
it's 100 pennies and a dollar that's how
much you're dealing with you can't work
it out so
if you raise the minimum wage to 15
bucks let's just say you raise the
minimum wage to 50 bucks
who's really affected by it does merrill
lynch care
no does wall street care no one in wall
street makes 15 bucks an hour
okay so the only people in wall street
that make 15 bucks an hour is who
maybe a 16 year old janitor i don't even
see that like
maybe and even an intern you know
doesn't even affect them
so who doesn't that affect go through
that wall street so
wall street funds most of these
politicians but they're not affected by
minimum wage you know what they're
saying
guys who cares about this minimum they
don't care
in their boardroom the last thing on
their mind is what 15
minimum wage so what do they say yeah
yeah yeah yeah go do it
so the most powerful people who are
funding these guys
and these guys are asking them we want
to raise a minimum wage to 15 they say
what they don't even call me on this man
i got other things to deal with
i'm i want regulation is what i'm
interested in
due to 15 so who's affected by 15 if you
think about it
restaurants hospitality whom you crushed
in the last 12 months so let me get this
straight
you destroy the small business owner
restaurant guys
and then on top of destroying them
you're telling them
i know you don't have any money in
savings guess what
here's some salt on your wound your
minimum wage of that person you were
paying
as a waiter a waiter and a waitress
makes what
minimum weight 725 but their money comes
from where tips
and i got to pay 15 an hour for my 12
waiters and waitresses
are you doing to me so i thought you
were for the little guy
i thought you were for the small
business owner what happened to you
being for this little guy
this minimum wage is not helping me out
you shutting me down even more
so now my sixty two thousand dollars
that depleted to fifty two thousand
dollars or forty three thousand dollars
now my payroll and my net profits go
smaller and smaller
so now my kid that was going to a nice
little private school and i have to take
him out of private school
now the additional money that was
spending not everybody's affected by it
this doesn't end up being tithing is
going to go down
money to charities all that stuff's
going to be effective prices are also
going to go up
that's the following thing you have to
raise prices
if a burger is four dollars be prepared
for eight dollars if you're buying
something sodas buck 50
be prepared for three dollars if you're
anything you're buying if minimum wage
doubles that price is going to double
okay flip side give me some pros give me
some pros
oh the pro is the the 16 year old kid
now gets a job
that has to pay 15 bucks an hour so the
16 year old's like dude that's awesome
now i can get 30 000
a year instead of 50. it's not just a 16
year old kid it might be
the uh 36 year old mother
of two who's you know was making
you know nine dollars an hour say that
again say that again
why are you 36 years old and making
minimum wage maybe
you're an immigrant maybe you're you
don't have a great education i mean
there's a million answers i'm sorry you
know there was a question
years ago a guy named scott walker who
was a former comptroller general the u.s
uh of which is like the chief accountant
of us it was a david walker i think his
name is david walker
and he came out with a documentary what
was the documentary called do you
remember what the documentary called
go type up and see what david walker's
documentary was
in the documentary they show an
interview where warren buffett is
talking
and this lady gets up and warren buff is
talking about how much debt the market
has how much this how much that and i
interviewed this guy david walker like
10 years ago
scott walker i believe was the no not
scott walker's i owe usa
i o usa was the documentary i-o-u-s-a
okay and buffett at the end is speaking
to a crowd of i don't know 400 people
and this lady says oh my gosh with all
the stuff going on what should i do i'm
a single mother how do i handle this and
and
warren says listen no matter what the
time is
there's always there's always a demand
for experts
go become good at what you do if you
don't do
what if you what you do you're not an
expert in there's no market for you
the market dictates your price but if
you're an expert in anything you do
you dictate your price so for the people
that are 36 years old making 720
what the hell are you doing at 36 years
old making 720 like maybe pick up a book
or two
maybe this is an identity issue and a
market doesn't
value enough that doesn't want to pay
you more than 720.
maybe you keep getting fired at your
last 10 jobs because your attitude needs
to kind of improve why have you got
i had a friend i talked to one time i
said why have you lost like
every time you come talk to me about
your jobs your boss are always
idiots how is it your last 10 bosses
were idiots there's only one common such
denominator amongst these 10 bosses
they all hired you yeah and they fired
you
so your bosses are idiots i'm sorry this
doesn't make make any sense
so there's an element of what you're
saying well who's it good for who's it
beneficial for
a lot of people that are not worth 15
bucks that are going to start getting
paid 15 bucks that's exciting it's also
how replaceable are you at
15 or 7 25
there's no differentiator just just be
ready to think about it this way
whatever you're paying for
right now double it yeah 725 to 15 bucks
be ready to double what you're paying
for today
groceries whatever it is if milk is 350
get ready to pay seven if you're okay
with that
vote for minimum wage and i'm just
thinking what type of person says all
right yeah i'll take i'll take the job
750 an hour i'm cool like i'll i'll take
it i need the job
i need the job it's not about look when
he came in he didn't negotiate a salary
he just came and says give me a position
i'm going to prove you who i am
so i'm like listen honestly and i'm like
mario can we figure
out a way to just move on because it's
technical he's coming from norway it's
this is that
he says pat this guy's emailed me so
many times i said what do you want to do
with them
you know we had to it was not an easy
thing to do to hire this guy because we
had to go
you spend you know we had to do some
additional stuff so finally we brought
him on board
he dictated his market value we didn't
do it for him
we didn't say this is your market value
he dictated that
we have a lot of people here that work
with us hey i think i'm worth this i'm
worth this oh really
based on what you're the same as you
were two years ago what's changed the
last two years
he's not the same as he was two years
ago he's changed
how come he is now mario the vp of
operations why is mario running the show
here because
do you know what i've touched ever since
i've been here with this office what
have i touched can you tell us what i've
touched
the coffee maybe i've done i don't even
drink coffee nothing
everything here's come together the
finding of the office is everything
shout out to mario because mario ran the
entire show
then during that time who helped out
that was here you
eric mickey mario for a week you guys
were working day and night getting this
whole thing situated until these guys
could come back from
you know not that they weren't working
they just had they were moving they were
moving they were dealing with no not
moving they had
health matters you couldn't be here so
it's not about the they were dying to be
here these guys are workers i want to be
here
i didn't want to throw you under the bus
buddy is that your movie i just said
health i didn't get specific i just said
they had enjoyed my vacation so
so but but here's the moral of the story
the moral of the story is what
you determine your market value that
that concept people want to fight but
unfortunately
it's the truth you dictate
your value in the marketplace if you
make 20 grand a year that's what you're
worth
that's not what i'm worth i'm priceless
really go put your resume online
go put your resume on i see what they
tell you i'm worth
at least forty five thousand dollars go
test it out
they're paying me for i think i'm worth
150 go put your resume online
you know what in netflix they even
recommended that like go go go
talk to your personality but by the way
the point is
if you are worth that the company's
going to have to pay you because the
company doesn't want to lose you they
call it they call it
different names for it rockstar
principal say bankable employee
i don't want to lose this guy you want
me to go through another process of
hiring another kind that has this much
now inventory in the company to
go why would i do that no so we have to
take care he doesn't need to come to us
for a raise
you understand what i'm saying so when
it's when it's the other way so in the
marketplace today
15 minimum wage 15 minute wage it's
unfair
what's unfair is the fact that you spend
40 hours a week watching netflix instead
of reading books
that is unfair what's unfair is the fact
that
you come home eating chips not taking
your body versus let me go work out a
little bit for 30 minutes to 45 minutes
that's unfair and that's your choice
nobody forced you to stay home and watch
tv all night long
but it's a great netflix show i don't
care
you know how you made fun of me you're
like you know this guy doesn't know who
weekend is i'm like i don't know who we
can this i mean obviously we're having
fun with it but
i don't take it personally but last time
i listened to the radios 2004
i don't care those guys don't make me
money from all four to 20 21 i know
nothing
about music i don't care i don't need to
listen to the radio so
people have to realize that they
have a choice if you are relying on a
minimum wage to dictate your value
the government dictates your value do
you know how much of an
insult that is i'd much rather say
let me work for you for 30 days you
dictate what i'm worth
30 days later i say let me tell you man
we're not going to find a guy like this
guy right here
we hey you know time we're not going to
find him we're all going to yeah we're
not going to find someone like this
let's just kind of
verses 15 minimum go ahead wow the
government says
that i'm worth i mean let's just break
down what
minimum wage is minimum this is like
the the the yeah your this is your your
bottom line this is what you could take
from it
so do you think there should be an
actual minimum wage
look should it be seven came out who
came out with the minimum wage
who came out with the management 61 what
is that uh no no 1961 is not who came
out with minimum wage minimum wage came
out by uh
fdr okay and you know what the first
minimum wage was
25 cents yeah is what it was and you
know why because
ford was abusing this
so they needed factories of course of
course industrial revolution
after that after all that so don't think
i'm all about like no regulation no
nothing you do need rules and guidelines
there needs to be a set of hey listen
here's the number what are you doing
i'm sorry here's what you got to do to
protect the employees that are working
there but 100
you need that but to there is there's
the pendulum right everything in life
has a pen on them this is why i'm
typically in the middle because the
middle is typically the right argument
for me because
we need a little bit of minimum yeah we
do need a minimum wage by the way
staying at 7 20 i think it's time we go
up from 7 20.
okay but i do think it needs to stay
different numbers by
what number what number i mean just give
me uh where you think it should go i can
do the math
big thing i don't think you should gloss
over that this is a state issue this
isn't a federal
it's not it's not and a lot of people
don't know how to differentiate
how much how much was gas here i filled
up the tank yesterday how much is gas
here
2 30. 250. how much is gas taxes 214
bucks
214. even by by the way you just went
from 260 to 214. what's the
people like that's not a big that's 44
cents that's a ver
what's 44 cents on two dollars and you
know
14 cents that's 20 percent four or five
bucks
it's like making 50 grand versus 60
grand i'm sorry that's a very big
difference that's not a small difference
now go to california what's a gallon
what's a gallon mario can you type in
california gas
price i think it's like 340 350. is that
what it is
so sorry uh yeah i don't i don't know
the number i filled up yesterday it was
350 for me so california is 349 but i
did 93 is what i did so because it's the
f150 so okay so just look at that okay
three four four
345 and see what new york is let's write
this down if california is 345
what if d7 is new york is that really
the case
for the new york new york city though
because upstate new york might be
where's new york new york is 257
interesting okay 257. is california the
highest by the way when you're looking
at that
california by the way is the only one
with three what are they firing this
morning
expensive too hawaii is still
lower than california how pathetic is
that the fact that california has the
highest
at 3 45. so so watch the math here watch
the math here
so 345 345
versus 257 okay 345
257 what's the difference in that 88
cents 88 cents divided by 257
is 34 so 34
on minimum wage of what 725 which is the
national right
725 times 34
is makes it 971.
so california minimum wage needs to be
what
10 or 50 10 10 or 12 bucks essentially
if we're looking at math okay all right
what does new york have to be cost of
living then i'm doing math and i'm just
doing gas by the way i'm not doing rent
i'm not doing
house i'm not doing all that other stuff
new york gas may be lower but real
estate's ridiculous right with rent what
they got
so then you say if it's new york city
man new york city kind of needs to be 15
bucks
if you're new york city it's kind of got
to be 15 bucks but i'm not giving just a
flat 15
if i if all i did was i got paid as an
accountant to come up with numbers
we would come up with numbers based on
math and present it to the governors and
say guys can i make a recommendation to
you
based on this math here's where you need
to be now it's on you
then i would make that a public letter
that we had a conversation with 50
governors and this is the recommendation
we made i would make that paper public
and say
our recommendation to your governor is
this based on this formula that we use
now if you like your governor go tell
your governor to raise it if not
replace it with somebody else and bring
shamath in instead of newsom
but the choice is on you here's the math
we gave you let the voters decide what
they want to do
where is that part like that that's the
approach i'd be taking here's a number
we're looking at
it's too linear or non-dimensional to
just lay a flat across the board look
you i'll talk to uh tom i'll talk to you
know
and they'll come and say patrick here's
this person that we want to hire this is
the market value right now for this
person
so what do you suggest i think here's
what we need to do if you don't do it
someone's going to pay for this
okay got it and hey we have this person
existing employee if we don't pay
someone's going to pay for it
but this person last time we had a
conversation this person didn't want to
take this and this person didn't want to
do that let's move on let's let this
person go and get their next victory not
a good place at our company
culture doesn't fit let's let them go
we'll go find somebody else
okay but there is that decision
of what somebody wants to do 15 across
the board
every state makes no sense from a
business owners makes no sense
who has all sorts of employees making
you know low to medium to
ridiculous you know amount of money
do you pay anybody minimum wage do you
have a like what's your philosophy when
you're hiring
you know entry-level workers
underwriters what have you
well how do you process that minimum
when it comes down to
php uh i i i don't know the exact
data as of today but i am speculating
when i say this
i don't think we pay anyone less than 15
bucks an hour
okay nobody and if we do maybe it's one
so if minimum age
you're like i could care you don't pay
attention to it yeah but but
but you're looking for talent i mean
what is it no because because we sat
there
and my staff came up to me and they said
to me
you want better pool of talent for us to
get resumes up
we have to be above 15 bucks and i said
great let's do that i didn't say
they came to me if if we go at 10 you're
getting this
if we go 12 you're getting this if we go
15 we can ask for this if we go 18 you
can ask for this if you go 22.
so they presented to me in a very
reasonable way and i said
okay great if that's the case then
here's what we need to do we need to
raise it because we want better
experience quality talent that comes
with a better resume let's pay for it
and then we made the decision that way
it wasn't like we have to save the money
and make sure we don't pay anybody man
no it's not demand it's talent it's
talent
it's talent it's who's gonna bring value
for the company
that's what you have to be thinking
about now at the beginning stages when
you start a business what are you
looking at saving i got to save money i
got to stretch this dollar into three
dollars i gotta
everything is about stretching it but
later on
better quality talent in the company the
better you do
okay because you got collective so i
don't i don't know about this 15 minimum
wage
there's much better ways to go about
this 15
minimum wage i don't like it i don't
like the direction they're going
um and hopefully somebody's going to
come in and do something about it with
this 15
minimum wage so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
you